rewrite the expression below applying
the q
commutative and associative properties
of addition and then show that both
expressions yield the same result so one
we could just evaluate the expression
the way it's written and then we can
kind of mess around with it using the
commutative and associative properties
of addition so let's first add 17.5 plus
three so that's going to give us 20.5 so
this is going to be 20.5
and then to that we're going to add
negative 7.5 now adding negative 7.5 is
the exact same thing as subtracting 7.5
so this is going to be equal to the 0.5
cancel out and then 20 minus 7 is
20 minus 7 is 13. so that's our first
way of getting the answer and we kind of
adhered to the parentheses now let's use
the commutative property the commutative
property tells us that the order doesn't
matter we can commute these numbers
around they can move commute it's like
you're going to work they can they can
move around so let's just move the
numbers around let's make it let's make
it we could actually we could do it all
sorts of crazy things we could make it
one week well let's just we could just
change the order here we could make this
negative
7.5
negative 7.5 plus
17.5
plus 3 we could keep the parentheses
just like that so we would have
essentially just changed the order of
this expression right over here but
let's use both the commutative and the
associative property so now we've
commuted everything around and now we
can reassociate everything so instead of
putting the parentheses like that we
could put the parentheses
we could put the parentheses like that
so that's what the associative property
tells us let me write this down so
associative
associative property of addition
tells us
that a plus b plus c
we do a plus b first is the same thing
as a plus b plus c
where you do b plus c first the
commutative property
the commutative
commutative
communitive
property
tells us that a plus b is equal to b
plus a that you can move these guys
around so let's evaluate this one we
actually got here using both the
commutative and the associative property
so we get negative 7.5
plus 17
this is the exact same thing as 17.5
minus 7.5 it might be easier for you to
realize okay i have the i'm adding two
numbers of different signs so what i
could do is take the difference between
the two and since the larger number is
positive i have a larger number or you
could just view this as 17.5
minus 7.5 so 17.5 minus 7.5 the 0.5
cancel out 17 minus 7 is 10. so this
part right here becomes 10 and then we
still have the plus
we still have the plus 3 there and that
once again is going to be equal to 13.
and we could keep commuting this around
and keep reassociating and no matter how
we do it we are going to get 13.